hi there steve kaufman here um
finally finding some time to do some
videos i want to
continue in my series of faqs frequently
asked questions about language learning
today i want to talk about you know what
do you do when you feel stuck you're
losing interest you don't think you're
making any progress
what can you do
well i'm going to answer that and i'm
going to give you a very important
secret about language learning
and and it is this
the brain because you learn in the brain
okay you don't learn in the classroom
you don't learn from a teacher those
things are
relatively unimportant it's the brain
how do you feed the brain what do you do
to the brain to make it learn well the
brain likes two things okay
one in order to learn something you need
a certain degree of repetition
however the brain likes to be challenged
the brain likes novelty you have to
stretch it a bit okay if you are into
physical training and you always do the
same exercise you are not going to put
on any muscle
and i believe the brain is the same way
now i'll give you an example and then
i'll explain the example is this i've
started studying czech
and so i spent a fair amount of time on
check this past week just one week
i go back to russian and i understand
everything much more clearly you
understand that i went to another
language i gave the brain a new
challenge it's struggling to piece
together the check
doesn't understand much of it when i
feed it again russian it just eats it up
whereas when i was giving it a steady
diet of russian it was starting to get
i wouldn't say fed up but it wasn't
noticing things it wasn't as sharp so
you can do this in a number of ways you
can start on a second language as i did
with check or
simply when you're studying a language
and as you know i'm a great believer in
in using input of course if you can
speak if you got people to talk to go
for it but in the meantime there's so
much you can do on your own
and but the suggestion is vary it okay
vary the kind of content you're
listening to and also vary the degree of
difficulty don't just listen to
difficult stuff or you'll get frustrated
but don't just listen to simple stuff
either
very often the language teachers tell
you that you you should always be in the
sort of
you know n plus one this is krashen's
theory just slightly just a little bit
difficult for you or you should only
listen to read material where you know
95 of the words always in the sense of
making it easy for you
i say that's fine do some of that but
also
make sure you give yourself
a challenge go after some difficult
stuff and you know
i don't know if it's 50 50 70 30 but you
need to be regularly giving yourself
difficult stuff to do where you don't
know the words where you don't
understand it you close the book you
still don't understand it but you've
challenged your brain and when you go
back to that other stuff that's easier
for you you'll find it even easier okay
so when you're feeling stuck and you
don't think you're making progress
challenge your brain and when you're
learning mix it up don't just give it
the easy stuff give the brain difficult
stuff make it work train it toughen it
up so that when go it goes back to the
familiar it'll just eat it up there you
have it that's my frequently asked
question what do we do when we get stuck
thanks for listening bye